We, who failed at this seminary, think that we have
to look back somewhere and tell our
parents, friends and teachers that we can do it if we do.
Everyone wonders what Lhasa did, this suicide bomber.
You didn't expect terrorism, did
you?
It's not the power that kills a human being. With my 10 billion yen,
it's good to have an unharmed or one gel.
First, I covered Nagisa-kun with
the
robe I took off and
protected it.
It's not like it's over in the village,
tee
goo
dare
We have a nameplate on our house It's
a contract with the government, so you who opened the teacher wo
n't have to pay any damages I
know
, like Sugimoto now
I know what other people do except for you.
Let's try family and friends
.
If you want, you
can sell this teacher to Paros